[Music]
thank you
hello good morning good afternoon good
evening good middle of the night
whatever whatever time it is where
you're watching and welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel with
Ceramics stormy bear and
Young Harris joining us talk Young
Harris
strong Young Harris repair
[Music]
44 years old I'm not doing it too badly
but um
you're the Wise Old American
really
[Laughter]
American
but yeah we're we are here this evening
to chat about a little bit of season
four of Stargate what we thought of the
show I likes um not so much likes and
generally you know oh I I got strong
feelings about this series but I got
strong feelings about most seasons of
Stargate but before we get into that
before we start telling us about all
about Stargate and whatever season four
what we've been up to this week
gentlemen
stormy what you've been watching Sir
I've been watching a bunch of stuff I
haven't been binging one single thing I
kind of spread it out this week
because my
um
five-week Stargate everything bins kind
of I need to spin [ __ ] out
uh speaking of Stargate though I did uh
I discovered something I I should have
known but I didn't you can order comic
books on your Kindle
so I got the uh like the season two
comic book of what was supposed to
happen in season two is in Stargate
Universe ah excellent and I read through
that that was there was a it was it was
fun it was it was cool to read and I
didn't have to
you know trudge around um
two or three dozen comic book shops to
find it I just ordered it on my Kindle
amazing there you go everybody get on
your Kindles
the the things I watched this week was
like uh watch down Westworld
one couple episodes that penny worth
penny worth is really good I'm just I
really didn't you know it was just like
ah it's not going to be it but it was
really good of course rings of power
uh and door I thought and door was real
is still
really good I got a a buddy at work that
just can't stand the thought it was just
he's protesting it because it's Disney
it's but it's there's a lot of hate on
it it's a lot of protesting going on in
there in the world yeah right
yeah
he does seem to be I don't know he just
he'll I've been shouting at him across
the room and door and then peer pressure
but it doesn't do any good
um also watching a bit of handmaid's
tale which was
I really love handmaid's Tale But
I gotta take that in bits and pieces
it's darker and [ __ ] this year I mean
last this last season it's just holy
crap
uh ants off to lose with moss for you
know directing it so well but
lots of cringe worthiness I've never
watched it I've seen it um I don't know
what it's on over here I've seen it but
I've never never watched it it's like uh
America next week
okay
Jesus
okay uh and then I'll um sorry catching
up on the last season of Archer now
that's
the stupidest show but I love that show
and that's how we get ants Lana uh and
the last thing was House of the Dragon
actually I thought they did really well
with the everybody's older thing I
barely noticed to be fair didn't bother
me
um I've got a question about that in a
minute but we'll we'll come back to it
remind me to ask the question about it
but um Harris what what you've been you
you've been what haven't you watched
this week
what haven't I watched that is a good
question there's like two movies I have
not seen in the theater and one of them
is Sigourney Weaver's new little one
with uh Kevin Klein but I don't know if
I'm gonna go see that uh I don't know if
I'm gonna see Bros either just because
that's I'm not much of a rom-com person
but I have seen everything else that's
been released this weekend which was
I guess I saw Amsterdam a week early
Amsterdam releases this next week uh
it is not getting all that good of
reviews but it is a very character
driven film and I I enjoyed
the actors having fun with what they
were doing the story's the most just
straightforward simple little narrative
possible and it takes the whole First
Act to get into the story but
I thought it was a fun film overall
great cast essentially just having a
good time uh but after that I saw Vesper
which I think y'all should both see as
oh you're seeing it today aren't you
but yeah it's not out here yet
ah well y'all are gonna like it it's
it's a it's a fairy tale just kind of
it's World building and a fairy tale all
in like a very sci-fi way it's it's fun
uh really original I I enjoyed it and I
got to see uh the filmmakers come out
and talk about that and Ryan Johnson the
guy that did Knives Out In The Last Jedi
he popped out and interviewed everybody
which was interesting I couldn't ask you
that question
myself there uh
but after that I saw smile the next day
uh on Friday and yesterday I saw dead
for a dollar which is a new Western uh
smile was terrifying and awesome uh also
somebody's very first film I think
they've directed a couple shorts and the
guy did excellent uh and dead for dollar
was I think Walter Hill who did the
Deadwood pilot and he's done a bunch of
other
uh westerns throughout time
it was decent it was pretty damn good uh
think his uh Twilight days might be over
as a director but it was still fun it
was a generally good Western besides
that I think I saw written rings of
power Rick and Morty House of the Dragon
Andor She-Hulk all the users
is growing a real dislike for it I mean
I keep watching it and every time I
watch it I'm saying why am I watching
this
why am I watching this again
it's I I I like it where I want to like
it and it's just not there it's not
funny and that that hurts because it
should be a comedy
purposefully aimed at women that's the
demographic they were it does seem
nothing wrong with that well seems to
have gone let's should we make a show
for women
and I'm just watching it going I think
the humor and stuff is like I think my
wife would like this
because men and women are different
people I know that's a big shock men and
women are different
um and it's just like I can't I just
don't like it but um I don't like a lot
of Marvel are doing at the moment now
it's a bit it's a bit of a worry but
yeah I mean Jessica is the showrunner
for it and I know you haven't seen Rick
and Morty but I know you know pickle
Rick the episode where he turns himself
she's the one who wrote the episode
uh really and she's doing all this
She-Hulk which you know if she did
freaking pickle Rick I expect the show
to be funny and I just haven't laughed
I've chuckled a couple of times but
it's trying to be funny I can tell you
the bits where it's trying to be I'm
like oh yeah we're trying to be a joke
I didn't find it funny
um and I'm like and I I know what
they're trying to do it's just yeah I'm
just I'm like saying it just doesn't
seem to be quite hidden
where it needs to hit
um
if it's not funny it should at least
dive further into hulking or dive
further into lawyering one of the two
attorney at law we haven't gotten much
lawyering and which would be interesting
in the MCU uh because there's a lot of
legalities to work out with in a super
powered world but it would be
interesting yeah
why do you think why do they think why
does Marvel seem to be just trying to do
comedies at the moment though I just I
don't I don't get it they're just going
really everything's just like the the
nice thing about Marvel before was it
was funny and bits because real life is
funny you know like um you know and when
things get horrible in real life which
is interesting when you see dramas and
they're not funny at all and they say oh
it's gritty in real life and I'm like
that's not I've been in really shitty
situations in my life and one of the
first things to do maybe it's a British
thing but the first thing we do is take
the piss out of everybody and you know
try not to blow our own brains out you
know we use humor to to break up things
I work for the NHS you know we have
death constantly we will joke about
we'll have Sweepstakes on when's the
first Ginger person gonna die that day
and things like this and it's just like
just just to try and break the ice
um
but
so when you see that so so in like say
Marvel movies when there's a bit of
humor I'm like yeah that's real life but
these they're making comedies and
they're just not very good they just
don't make it I they they they try
and it's they just don't land
for me
yeah I don't feel like the last thing
that actually was that took itself
seriously while still having fun it
wasn't as good as in-game or Infinity
war that but I think Ant-Man and the
WASP was the last one that actually felt
self-serious while still
in the Marvel kind of uh quirkiness
everything else since then including
Spider-Man which Spider-Man did feel
serious at Parts but I feel like it kind
of lessened some of the more dramatic
moments with bad decision making uh even
though I do like the film generally I
everything else has just been funny and
fun compared to fun funny and fun but
but serious and grounded at the same
time a realistically human though isn't
it you know somebody's a bit sarcastic
somebody's a big thing but it's it's
it's it's it's still grounded you know
that was the thing with Marvel it was
always grounded and it just seems and I
know they're going to try to do
different things they seem to be just
trying maybe a bit too hard maybe that's
the problem maybe they're trying to
force him I did see Morpheus the other
night I finally I'm seeing that
um it's it's not very good no there's a
reason why it bombed
Morpheus omorbius morbius amorphous
didn't I I was saying I was taking them
it was so bad I knew what you were
talking about yeah I saw a bloody awful
vampire movie Mobius yeah yeah
um it was pretty it was so bad I thought
DC had made it that's how bad it was
um it was it was just shocking but um
that's not fair it's good in places but
it was very much like
um
uh the other one oh uh Carnage and that
as well oh yeah Venom and Carnage it
just seems to be that it's really badly
edited it seems to be really jerky in
places and there's a bit
Circle you can tell they cut out like a
Tyrese Gibson said that he had a whole
other like
Arc to his character and we didn't see
anything of Tyrese Gibson in the movie
why hire Tyrese if you're gonna have him
in there for four scenes you know well
he's expensive
there's bitsy movie so again they just
don't explain let's just be like they'll
be um you know the whole blue blood and
red blood thing they they touch on but
they don't really go into any detail the
the best example I've got though is for
the way these films are made and edited
together was in venom carnage Venom sees
Carnage for the first time he goes oh
that's a red one I'm out of here I'm
trying to run away and then you know the
voices no no come on we've got to fight
okay I'll fight him now I'm going to
explain that at all why was Venom
worried about him being a red one
just don't explain it
and I'm saying I feel like that's the
sort of thing that should have been
explained and there's a couple of points
in morbius and I'm like the same I'm
like something's been cut out there and
they've not twigged that it was
important later
um you know I'm just like that's just
terrible movie but anyway
you didn't mention lower decks and they
did the Deep Space Nine episode and it
was Bloody brilliant I absolutely loved
it
so I'm loving lower decks this season I
love the bit at the very start of the
movie at the start of the bit they um
they don't want to um dock just yet so
it says just just see Blake going around
the ship and as if we're just like oh
look at the pylons and I'm just and then
they just
thought yes good poke fun though I like
that
so yes other than that um one question I
wanted to ask about House of the Dragons
somebody put a comment
um today about it being woke
and so I asked why and they said it was
because of gender politics and so I
asked why and they couldn't really
explain just very very quickly any
freaking clue he's talking about
in-house in the dragon yeah I don't get
it I assume it's because the male the
female roles are the powerful roles in
it
you know
um yeah um
somebody once asked the the arth author
you know why he always had uh such
strong female characters and he said
something like well because I I write
them as people
mm-hmm you know and we're all scared of
our mums yeah and and
um
[Music]
and I always found that kind of
intriguing that it was
well yeah they're people so you have I
mean if you look at Game of Thrones it
is a mishmash of male and female power
characters uh mishmash of gender
mishmash of failures mishmash of
everything you know lovers Fighters
comedians
murderers and uh it was and I just
gender politics and
I think
I'm usually I'm usually kind of
sensitive to that so I can make fun of
it but I just
I I I don't know I I don't see it I
really really don't see it sure raynus
was supposed to be the queen at one
point and Rainier is supposed to be the
queen going forward but at the same time
there's the whole plot of the show is
people saying yeah we don't want that
and we're fighting back against that and
her having to prove that which is not
necessarily
I guess gender politics it's it's a
human trying to boost their place inside
of their house in an ancient time I
don't know it all makes perfect sense I
think and it actually happens in history
in the UK one of our most powerful she
was actually kind of the warrior Queen
was Queen Elizabeth I'm the first you
know and she um she basically saved well
she was one age yeah when Spain yeah
when dysentery was really a problem it
wasn't the Golden Age we all [ __ ] in the
streets mate
um the Golden Age
um but people nostalgically back in
history now flushing toilets thank you I
win we win so you know a lot of people
that I meet that are British or
astonished that I know so much about
early British history and I keep telling
them well you have to understand that
British history is American history up
until 1776 and then we really did we're
not taught a lot after that you know of
British history except maybe World War
II Churchill et cetera et cetera but
it's like yeah that's part of American
History is British history happened to a
point you know and then we threw their
[ __ ] teen armor
[Music]
that's right bro
yeah but anyway I did he did come back
to me and sort of said I reject all
these sort of things because it's not
realistic and I'm like nobody ever said
that about an army movie a watch
Commando no point in that movie is that
um realistic you know because he's a man
he's not a Mary Sue he literally doesn't
get a scratch on him in that entire film
and an entire arm he tries to shoot him
it's not remotely realistic so sometimes
films aren't realistic I know it's a
shock but anyway let's get away from
that because I always get in trouble
when I talk about work
um people yell at me uh and another
subscribe
um so Stargate season four season four
Young Harris has just finished watching
it for the first time
um they grow up so fast I know so
replicators really do
yeah yeah
okay like oh mate you haven't you
haven't seen season six and seven and oh
they grow up wow yeah
um but I'm just gonna throw this out
there to begin with and I'd love to know
what you guys think I remember
I distinctly remember watching the first
episode of small victories
um when it aired in the UK and I
remember I genuinely remember going this
is next level
and knowing that the show had sort of
matured and had become it overtook Star
Trek for me that time that's that's when
Stargate became my favorite TV show was
this season and and particularly small
victories
um you know the whole Russian sub thing
the whole O'Neill and thought that's but
I'd love to know what you guys think
what did you think of um what's your
just when you think about this season
what's just your first thought well I
mean similar to you I mean there's a lot
happening in this season you know we're
you know there's small victories with
the replicators there's the new Stargate
that the Russians have we introduced to
the unas you know
excuse me we were introduced to the Unos
for the first time and there's a lot of
first time introductions that kind of
set up episodes for the next seasons
coming up you know
there's a lot of episodes that set up
things for the next season yeah
um
particularly sorry no I've got three or
four episodes left to season five and I
think four or five episodes ago was the
second Unis episode when you get to meet
all that and Daniel Jackson uh
is obviously the guy that kind of Saves
the Day of course in that but I I that's
might be my favorite episode of the
whole fourth season just introducing
like the original Uno's Homeworld and
the original Gould Homeworld as well
right
now I'm a vegetable Builder fan can I
just point out this comments because I I
just put a comments in the video and
it's generally made me laugh in my brain
because I've never thought about it
before but
still want me to look a bit like that
that's that's never occurred to me but
yeah a little bit why have I just got a
chopper ball appear in my thing
Danny DeVito's penguin for uh Halloween
get you some good makeup going well for
Halloween
Gandalf [ __ ]
you're gonna grow the beard out a little
bit or what's the plan well I'm working
ah cool
but yes that was that that I'm used to
me I'm sorry but anyway the the the the
the but the favorite thing the favorite
thing that happened in season four for
me was the introduction of Martin
which later on gave us Wormhole extreme
Wormhole X extreme which was just oh my
God
that was great that was great it
introduced us to the final member of the
de Luis family yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
literally every de Luis that's ever been
alive
it's been like five of them in this and
you know the youngest how did they get
so hooked up to that show I never could
figure that out it's because one of the
producers was um as Peter DeLuise
I mean it seems you know I mean on the
show
that's how they got Dom DeLuise to do
history and it was obviously it's his
dad
um and then
um oh you're gonna have to remind me
what was the boyfriend's name I think it
comes in season five doesn't he Pete
Pete so PT's a de Luis and then the
woman extreme guy that's supposed to be
O'Neill is another de Luis and then
there was uh does it say colonel in my
uniform Peter deluise's wife isn't it at
one point I think she's playing some
sort of alien there's like honestly
there's like six of them
they're all related so um so yeah Google
that one of the days and yeah there's
loads of them
um I actually think Stargate did a story
on it not long ago actually talking
about like the family the Stargate
family and it was really interesting
about how many relationships started on
the show and things
um but then it has the the boys and it's
all that all the television
but yeah Michael Shanks met his his
first girlfriend who had a child with on
the show and then he obviously met his
now wife
um I can never remember to say her name
but like stoig or whatever however you
say that he met her on the show he was
lost she uh the first time I saw her was
on uh Andromeda Kevin torbo show you're
so gorgeous
by the way did you know Kevin Sorbo is
insane
he is it's kind of disappointing how
insane he is he's an absolute rocker
yeah this week so I I accidentally fell
on his Twitter feed oh dear God I had to
block him because
everybody that I was following [ __ ]
about him and popped up my face I just
gotta block this guy and I ran through
his [ __ ] and he's like you've got to be
kidding and then I
and then Lucy Lawless at one point
jumped in and then it got very
entertaining so I had to unblock it
oh my god
oh man I'm completely side note but I
only found out this week [ __ ] lunatic
if you've been relegated to only
Christian movies for the past eight
to five
yeah oh and he blames everybody else for
that as well it's everyone else the
reason why I'm not in Hollywood is
because everyone's so Nancy Wally no
that's a [ __ ] what was another uh Rob
Schneider Schneider
um you know it's been bitching about oh
I'll risk my career for to talk about my
beliefs in the Maga or whatever and it's
like aren't you aren't you the guy that
this pops up as a cameo in all of Adam
Sandler's movies aren't you know and is
that where you're at now
Rob Schneider's not all Maggie he's he's
he's more of leave everybody alone I
like Rob Schmidt
um
uh what's his name is it Glenn Beck's uh
show and really let her rip
lordy yeah accessorize that politics
look I I had a stand-up fight with
Joseph malozi because he's a um he's a
climate change tonight and I I have
actually had to block him and the thing
is when I learned is don't don't talk to
your Idols you know this guy was one of
my heroes he's you know he helped to
create one of my favorite shows ever
um and
it got unpleasant
um it got really nasty and because
that's you know climate change and you
know something I'm quite passionate
about that you know I actually want to
leave a planet for my
great-grandchildren
um and his politics were
not pleasant
so you know it did get really really
nasty but anyway let's get what if he
owns any property in Florida
well that's I'll be underwater soon
um
again
let's get back to Stargate so yeah
Stargate series for little victories
like I said for me just the best he's
gone again where's he gone he keeps
doing this he keeps running off that AC
turned on I had to turn it off real fast
the kids today they can't concentrate on
anything for more than two minutes
80d as can be that's why I had to go see
the movie theater so many times a week
just kind of focus a little bit you know
don't need AC in this country it went
from 40 degrees to 20 degrees to 10
degrees in like three weeks
but it's freezing you know it doesn't
stop raining for like two weeks but
anyway so small victories like today for
me we see the O'Neill that's a ship that
we we hear again and again in the series
which I just love we barely knew her
yeah
um we'll talk about how the series ended
because the series ends with just like
a reference that that just gets repeated
I'd like to see it in the comments does
anybody know what I'm talking about just
let's see if anybody can it's too good
I'm talking about a reference that just
gets repeated over and over and over and
over again for the rest of the seasons
and going into
Atlantis as well but is it indeed
no it isn't indeed come on it's more
complicated
more complicated than that but
my favorite episode in all of Stargates
in this season uh a window opportunity
which I think talking about Marvel
trying to do funny and it failing
Stargate they did funny it did funny I
mean I've watched that episode about 10
times and it still makes me laugh
properly out loud
um to the point where I've got a t-shirt
on sitebastreck.com
with a golfing swing and a Stargate logo
my favorite Stargate design
I'm getting myself a hoodie and I'm
getting myself to start that that logo
I've decided I need to get it at some
point just getting cold
um
how about you guys is it is there one
episode that like jumps into you just go
that was just like
genius sort of thing in this season
because there's a few
there's a few
anyone in particularly wanna
toss out there
I don't know because I I've got about
three I think that are kind of almost
tied for me just because I mean I'm such
a big fan of World building and I always
go back to it but it when it's done well
and integrated into a story and it's not
like all right we're taking 15 or 10
minutes five minutes even to go build a
world instead of focus on what's going
on I uh I I thought the first ones with
the Unis and the Gould episode was great
I saw I loved the Watergate episode with
uh the Russian going into the underwater
world over there and getting caught
um
love the Star Trek connection see I
don't know the Star Trek connection
Deanna Troy the Russian chick yeah let's
see some Star Trek she's Tiana Troy
she's she's also a British actress she's
a oh God now forgotten her name Marina
certis Marina certis
um very pretty I liked her very much in
Star Trek
um but yes that she was in Star Trek the
Next Generation
okay when that episode was great just
because
one of my favorite things about Stargate
in general is going to explore all these
different worlds all these different
cultures all of these different species
and aliens and these things and
hell I don't know if we'll ever even go
back to it but just the where my mind
goes from that that could have been I
mean for all intents and purposes as of
now that is Atlantis in my mind or would
lead to it kind of deal or the closest
thing to it in the Stargate Universe
just because there's a whole alien
subspecies living inside of a water
City that's crazy yeah yeah I I enjoyed
it it made my brain think just knowing
that Atlantis was there Stargate
Atlantis I was like does this correlate
will this correlate probably not but
could it correlate into a new series
later down the road you know I I started
just thinking
um but then I really liked the
reintroduction of Osiris and Sarah uh
and and the death of um
Daniel Jackson's old
Professor or not doctor Professor
probably a professor yeah
I thought those were just all really
well done and kind of different ways but
really particular and and
meticulously well done I I'd say
well one thing that I want to know is
why is Harris's head so small
I think he's so tiny he just it's just
I'm thinking
it's okay
our biggest moisture head so big
you're freaking enormous don't need to
veto's head ain't that big
okay so so one episode and huh I I'm
chalking it up to rocket science
okay sure that's our Aviation field does
to a person just inflates their head a
massively
there there's one episode that I really
liked
but then I really kind of dreaded today
I dread the concept and it the title of
the episode well it's where you know the
uh a shin
have a run-in with sg1 2010 yeah and uh
the the uh yeah the the the title of the
episode is 2010 is filmed in 2000 it was
premiered in 2001
and that was 21 years ago
two decades
yeah oh crap got them old right I mean
it's the title in the in the premiere
date and it's just like
damn it that was 21 years ago and then I
have to go up every time this hits me I
have to go take a nap I mean it's
I mean this was such good Sci-Fi and it
even with at the time the effects were
really really sharp Sci-fi channel did
something like this but it's like that
was 21 years ago yeah
we're talking about it today which is a
testament to its quality but
we're used to win that face 21 years ago
Harris south of yeah that was two or
three
that was somewhere between two and three
or three at that point
Aaron shut up I just don't want to hear
I'm kicking my [ __ ] I was three
years
come out
of the century last of the 90s babies I
can't really count myself as a 90s baby
though kind of
actually I I hate that I was um I was
listening to there's a thing on the
radio the other week and it was in 1997
and they were playing a game they'd play
a track from 1997 and then they would
play a song another song is yesterday it
was it before or after and then they go
1997 for me was just like that's when
music just everything died after that
and I'm like loving these songs and then
I suddenly did the math and I was like
ah [ __ ] this is like I still own all
these albums
[Laughter]
um but but yeah
um another episode I loved though
um which I thought you'd inject it was
which if we're talking about episodes
that are then important for the rest of
the seasons and really right change
direction of where Stargate was going
and this is that first thing was the
episode tangent where we see the x301
for the first time the park gold so it
would captured some gold death gliders
and we'd use some good old and probably
British Ingenuity let's be honest you
know there's a bunch of British
Engineers if you know your American
aviation history
you know it was just so we built you an
x301 and then you got to mass
manufacture it which is how that works
um but
um
and then I love that bit in in the
episode obviously they have
um the the it's actually a profits I
can't remember now anyway the Hologram
pops up because you have you know been
naughty and your God is angry and we're
taking it back and so the x301 Flies off
into space and they have to go rescue
um
but I I love that episode is because
that showed us the first signs of where
they were going with Stargate over a few
seasons so I mean it doesn't really
it's not really a massively important
episode it's not the best episode of
thing but yeah I just that showed us the
first signs then and then obviously with
the x302
and then the Prometheus not long after
so if you go to the community yet it was
like the hinge of humanity was no longer
dependent on scraps of Technology they
found through the gate uh you know they
sort of develop really developing their
own Tech to travel and it was about b as
we saw
but yeah the Prometheus etc etc and then
they started expanding what they had
and of course at the end of the series
you know it was dominance
and that episode when they they showed
that is like this is where we're going
and we're no longer you know just
pulling out of the gate you know just
trinkets that way fine we've actually
with the help of the Asgard a little bit
you know this is where we're going yeah
but we need the chills very defendable
ship the Prometheus no actual fight to
it I did a video on the prison long ago
because it from a weapons point of view
it was useless and but nobody could
touch it because that has guard Shields
so I was like until somebody did touch
it and blew it in half but house doesn't
know that yet spoilers
that was the thing for me though this
was the point when we stopped just going
through the gate with machine guns and
started actually
working towards being actual starter
it's it's there's a beautiful thing
about Stargate wasn't it it's always
realistic and it's sort of like the show
had to evolve in that direction because
obviously we had this enemy that we have
to go and fight in the Gold World
um and we weren't going to just do that
the way we were doing it in the first
three series we had to start taking the
fight to them at some point
um and this was that first big step but
they never rushed it and that was the
thing I liked for Stargate it was never
rushed it was always
step step step sort of thing and it
feels natural all the politics to help
it feel natural I mean it it's nice it
that's the best part about the show
um that the politics is yeah I think so
there's a couple of episodes here where
the politics get involved isn't there as
well
um
I mean we could talk about Chain
Reaction a little bit but I mean
that's that's we're talking I'll talk
about that in a little while
um I really enjoyed the Prodigy episode
actually with um Jennifer Haley
um yeah I started to write a um a script
for everyone else script um something
like fan fiction and I was basing it
around this character Jennifer Haley she
really stood out in my mind she was the
captain or the the colonel in charge of
an x305
um uh BC 305 sorry in my fan fiction but
because I work 40 hours a week I've
never written more than about two pages
but I will at some point I'll try
um but yeah I really like that episode
because again it showed more depth to
the actual the reality of what the SGC
would actually be like that they would
actually have to go out there and try to
find
the brightest and the best
to come and fulfill the ranks eventually
so I like the ground
I like that she was a immediately
introduced as like a foil to Samantha or
Sam too yeah she's just as smart just as
capable but uh
a little headstrong sometimes which is
good and bad and I think they showed
both sides of that which was fun
and she's only tiny
tiny tiny little girl
when she came back
that's a normal sized water bottle he
drinks it's just that he's obviously
oh my God you've hit it the water bottle
is normal size
that's why he's so far away look bless
him that chair is one of those if you
guys got Playmobil in America
Playmobil what I mean by Playmobil so
they do like little plastic cars but
they do for everything toys
and they love little [ __ ] Playmobil
you must not blame you must have you
must have Playmobil
but then they do uh I was just saying
he's actually setting a Playmobil chair
we have locked Halls is that the same
thing in the Playmobil
you'll you'll notice it so I've got to
show this to the character now so that's
a Playmobil person so what's that called
in America
Fisher Price toy Christ
anyway okay Fisher-Price he's actually
starting to Fisher-Price chair this
isn't going anywhere such a British joke
but anyway moving on
um Chain Reaction the episode Chain
Reaction
so Hammond retires just like out of
nowhere it's your time
um and then we get that Major General
Bauer we're talking about realistic
episodes in the nid this was a this was
a good episode and we got to see that
piece of [ __ ] um Kinsey again as well
but um
for me that was one of the standout
episodes for me and any episode where we
get um oh his name's gone up my head
sorry maybe
in any episode we get mayborn is uh yes
is is always a good one and this is
where May born okay would be excited for
him the second he's on screen I'm just
getting out at this point
what's gonna happen
mate where he goes in the later episodes
you genuinely honestly we could sit here
for the next hour with you just having
suggestions on where he ends up and you
won't get close
it's just so good yeah it's so good you
literally you could like honestly it's
like trying to imagine what Donald Trump
would do back in the 1990s and you
wouldn't [ __ ] get close to what he
actually then did it's a similar sort of
thing you could become the most extreme
thing you could think of you're not
getting close but um I'd have to watch
The Simpsons they could help me out they
could predict it
yeah they probably they probably do
things
presidency I think in like late 90s
early 2000s yeah they did there's that
whole thing of him coming down the
escalator and it's like he actually do
it but anyway so the episode chain
reaction what did you guys think about
because I mean that's
great that's one of those episodes that
stands out and as well I always love I
love the weapon thing as well they did
um that they you know they realize that
all these gold places were on aqueda
um deposits that's why they had strong
calls there so they had this weapon that
could like to basically just wipe out an
entire planet
and then they do it it's just like
the reason I like that episode is
because I can actually see our leaders
thinking like that it's just like well
what can we do this is promote before
the Prometheus before the deadliest
before any of this so what can we do
build a massive freaking bomb and that
that's what we can do
um Hammond is in the way so we'll get
rid of him sort of thing
yeah I think it really turned up the uh
definition of what how far the nid is
willing to go to achieve whatever their
goals are you know we kind of see them
as this bothersome before this we see
that this bothersome kind of Rogue
agency that's really just a pain in the
neck you got to work around and then
they go do some [ __ ] like that
kidnapping children and then it just
really turns it really turned it up to
11 in terms of how
lack of morals the nid was but it's
proper cold warship it's a sort of thing
yeah it used to go on you know it's just
like
um we'll build a bigger Bond well we'll
assassinate this person will do it's
proper cold war but obviously it's not
it's not cold war and the fact that they
then bombed somebody but
um you know it's just like if that's why
it's unbelievable for me it's just like
this sort of thing this is the sort of
[ __ ] this this is how these people think
because they think that was the thing
about the nid which I always loved as
well they think they're the good guy
you know they think they're just making
those tough decisions this you know
these are the things
we're doing this because we have to not
because we want to and that's that's
where and a lot of these characters
yeah it's just the tough choices
so this is one of those episodes that I
was audibly yelling at my screen at
multiple points in the episode and
that's when I know it's a damn good
episode is because you know you're you
don't want Hammond to retire you don't
all these things are very realistic in a
evil political kind of way you know they
keep kind of
taking people back putting people in
yeah yeah it's as soon as it seems
Kinsey turns up as well I always know
it's going to be it's like um this
episode's gonna make me angry
and that's all I know but again Kinsey
it wasn't a bad guy you know he just he
thought he was doing what he had to do
he thought he thought he knew back you
know and he was um
I love Kinsey in that episode where it's
the where the president comes in you
know the best filler episode ever when
they have the new president and Kinsey
he's yelling he's literally yelling at
the president that how dangerous all
this is and then he starts talking about
God and the president felt like no no
believe that no like forget that
business but there's some people like
that think you know they think there's
only one God honestly no let's not let's
leave that one we're actually talking
about the end of the world [ __ ] let's
let's not start going on that line
something so yeah hold up you you know
of people walking through a gate to
different worlds
Dimensions timelines the different
things he's read all these reports and
and
still I mean come on now you've got
priorities
shall we get to the end of the series
end because I always think the the start
of the series in the end of the series
is what really generally stand back
don't know for most most Sci-Fi series
in particular and the the only thing
that maybe is the mid-season when they
have those mid-season doubles you know
there's like in the classic 22 episode
series things but the end of the series
he's almost as good as the start of the
series but the bit I was trying to and
nobody jumped in the comments the bit I
was trying to allude to was when Sam
destroys a star yes yes and you have the
thing again and she how many times then
in the later episodes does Harris not
know what I'm talking about but they
should go I don't know you destroy one
little star
that comes up so many times over and
over again in the series but
um
that was also for me though it was an
absolute like genius storyline in that
um
again it was we were just using what we
had weren't we you know we an
opportunity arose and then someone smart
as well we could destroy a stop and like
it was like let's think about the Box
Carter and then there's thinking out the
box he said go something about this but
what did you guys think about the about
the season finale and and we can talk
touch on the three episodes
because that was again a three-parter
well I mean it's yeah I think the start
the season started off strong ended
strong had a lot of strong points uh
throughout the season
that carried the story on into other
Seasons but yeah you know you destroyed
one star which kind of makes Samantha
Carter the most destructive force in the
universe
yeah she's like R2D2 of uh Stargate
yeah it's just like the MacGyver
YouTube
yeah but um yeah no I I I'm sorry so you
saw it for the first time recently I
mean how does it I've used to know how
you think it stands up to remember this
show is 20 years old nearly I didn't
stand up for some of the stuff you're
watching nowadays though
I mean that's interesting because
you know things are very different in
the way they're modeled now it's 10
episode 8 episode 6 episode 12 episode
kind of deal depending on what it is
some shows are 14 and 16 but that's like
The Walking Dead and I don't even think
they do that anymore uh
but
for for like stormy said there's clear
like good episodes throughout the entire
season and uh I I really like the way it
ended because it almost felt like when
O'Neil and teoch are stuck out in space
that that was foreshadowing what was
happening at the end of the season
uh
uh which which was nice it kind of
primed your brain and say okay we're
gonna spend some time away from
everybody but these big things are still
gonna happen and there's only certain
ways to get out of it of course I I
don't know I just thought it was really
well done uh I think if if this was to
come out now
I don't know if it would be any less
cheesy in any ways like with like comedy
per se but I
I don't know I feel like they are doing
Marvel comedy current Marvel comedy
better than Marvel's doing Marvel comedy
right now yeah if that makes sense so I
I I wouldn't change a thing uh for the
most part
well we changed something here today
Sidetrack we got rid of the hood so we
didn't need that guy at all
so let's talk about woke while he's gone
how much work can we get into American
wokeness let's let's go right now
our soap opera is woke
our soap operas not woke I think
I mean all it is is divorce
symbolism cheating
and more alcoholism I mean if you notice
they come into a room and they pour
themselves a whiskey or something and
every single and then it's like no one's
an alcoholic
true and you know it's the realism I
that's the good part about the Soaps
okay we gotta stop talking about work
he's back stop trying to destroy my
channel
I worked really really hard on this damn
Channel stop but we don't care there's a
way to see it every week you say the W
whatever I am doing my own
good did you see that video I did on
both sides Channel where I told people
to stop saying woken about how angry
people got I'm I'm doing fine destroying
my channel on my own
how are you helping
right
nowadays I could go off because my some
of the but I could still hear you
oh well there we go let me back in
quickly
I know stormy too well where his brain
could take if he's given the opportunity
dear Lord
Laurel
so Stargate series four where do you
think it fits
um I I I'm gonna ask you a bit more
Harris about what you think about how it
fits I think we'll go back in a second
yeah bringing his brain some more where
does it fit with the rest of the series
you think where does it
just just generally what do you think
about how important this series is
compared to what we've seen up to that
point
stormy or Harry oh no Harris looked like
you're about to say something yeah no I
I I had to think for a second because if
this was a season one I think I would
have liked it just as much I think it's
a season four is definitely my favorite
so far actually not I'm almost done with
season five and I really like everything
in season five but I really do like
season four uh and it's my favorite full
season that I've seen so far I can say
but if it was a first season I think it
would have been an excellent first
season but I like you said earlier I
like that Stargate took its time to get
to where it is because it's that much
more meaningful when you get there
compared to that that would have been a
really good first season they would have
introduced a whole lot of cool Concepts
and a lot of things but at that point
you're almost past the machine guns just
jumping through a gate and hoping for
the best and you're taking out ghouls
here and there uh
I I I feel like it's it's where a
turning point your first three seasons
were almost kind of like and or one two
three it's almost like an act one two
three and that's where you're really
delving into like the meat and and then
the muscles of uh
uh of of of the framework I guess of the
show now
and I I'm thoroughly enjoying the
hardcore sci-fi yeah I really enjoy it
the world building's still there the
whole show up till now has been a lot of
World building which just made me happy
but now I'm getting the Sci-Fi goodness
alongside of it which I never wasn't
getting the Sci-Fi goodness but it's
more inherent now I think it's it's the
humanity is getting the Sci-Fi there
isn't it as well so we're getting we're
we're moving from Beyond that all the
Sci-Fi came from the gold wall before
now it's like it's us it's awesome what
do you think
well I think uh this season was the
first time
that oh Neil well it took a couple
seasons for O'Neill's character to
really tolerate
um
Captain Carter at that time uh-huh not
the Carter and by the time you know we
get to uh this season
you know he full you know in one of his
little uh time Loops he resigns and then
French kisses her in front of General
Hammond and you know we finally
understand that yeah he's in on this too
but he's just really restrained and I
can only imagine the Furious
masturbation that goes on at Colonel
Emil's house this place continues to try
to kill my channel okay yeah I said
Furious master I received episodes with
I didn't say Jack was jacking off no no
you did we see the episode with the toe
Crowther don't we win
it looks like it looks all the way
through like O'Neill and Carter have
been like programmed or something by the
governor no
they're triggering the system because
they love each other and they're lying
about it yep and that's that's
it you know
sorry house
was just saying that was a great episode
yeah
a friend of mine used to have this
little profile picture of uh that scene
it was just that one frame of where
O'Neill had drawn the crazy happy face
and ketchup and mustard on the paper
plate and held it up
so that was always entertaining to see
that
um you know my favorite meme from um
Stargate I think is
um it's a Star Trek one at the time
where we got ah I could still hear it
we can hear you
yeah
with a full Danny DeVito cosplay watch
out
the um the one I liked though is that it
was a Star Trek thing at the top and it
goes um we we come to your primitive
thing we can't interfere we have you
know the prime directive and we do why
they want to interfere with your
religious beliefs and then underneath it
Stargate with the sg1 they're going your
guards are all fake here's some guns
some guns I really really love that
episode
um that that Meme sorry that keeps
appearing but um
uh so where are we at oh just a second
sorry I'm trying to oh I'm getting
bugged by people in other places
um
the one thing I was genuinely interested
in and I've not really thought about it
before Harris but like I say you've
never never watched Stargate before and
now it wasn't old farts
at first it's almost nostalgic but the
show is 20 years old you know which is
terrifying
it I know I'm gonna really hold that
point in you know and yeah keep going
keep going
um the one thing uh
um I think the first series was a little
dated and I think you can tell you can
tell that they add no budget you know it
was like nine hundred thousand dollars
an episode or something
um which is just you know for a Sci-Fi
seriously they stole a lot of special
effects from the movie because they just
didn't have the budget to do it there's
a whole scene where the Death guy to
come Sweeping in you saw a lot in the
first two three episodes through three
series you know it was just completely
taken from the movie like change the
background or something
um and no budget
by now though I think we've got I mean
the last episode
um Exodus was actually nominated for an
Emmy for a special effects right so you
know I think by this by this point but
from Harry's point of view of watching
it from the from new how do you
genuinely think it Stacks up to like a
new show if if this series came out
today
would we would we watch it or would it
or with like today
well by series four as is to be honest
by series 4 as is I would say yes I
think one two three uh
they're they're they're dated and not at
the same time I think they're dated in a
technology aspect they're dated in a way
where the effects just don't hold up now
so it kind of brings us into an uncanny
valley
um
but I mean you know I I love all the
World building but you can't have that
without intelligent writing and I think
the writing is what I
I would say the first three seasons
would do well today
um they might have to condense it and of
course discuss kind of how things work
our brains are not as uh
used to 22 episode shows and we kind of
want things to happen quicker nowadays
but I I think the first three seasons
would still do well nowadays with
updated Graphics just because of the
writing I I think it's really
intelligent writing and
they weren't necessarily ahead of their
time they're using math and Concepts
that we've known of uh in science for
the past half
uh Century I guess maybe longer but
I I would say they would
um besides the graphics just because of
the writing I I really enjoy it's smart
it knows what it is and you can tell
that whether it's malozi or whoever
writing the episodes did a [ __ ] ton of
research prior to going into all this uh
and it seems
big on sort of theoretical stuff as well
because you can always tell when it's
the bright white episodes it tends to go
into some sort of crazy
theoretical
sciencey thing whenever it's the time
you wind the episode someone's always
brought right there wrote it
um and you know yeah you can tell they
really thought about them as well well
you know I think a couple of live
streams ago it was not just the
technical stuff and the mathematics that
they always do a lot of heavy research
on it's also the Egyptian mythology I
was reading yes I started capturing I've
got a bunch of Egyptian mythology books
I started reading through this oh [ __ ]
they've really done their homework here
you know
yeah yeah I know they really did and I
think that's that sense to the reality
and the depth of it as well doesn't it
when there are all these little they
don't just name something do they they
don't just go oh this is our thesis
there's actually like a couple of
background I also think sometimes I
thought they went a bit too far with the
mythology and it's just like not
everything is affecting ancient Earth
myth I mean come on yes it did get to a
point where everything turned up because
oh well in in ancient hippies I was like
oh no come on man
um it's going a bit finer but you know
every system Lord was an ancient
mythology symmetry other every every
planet we went on was just like
something from history it's just [ __ ]
what no every time I see that damn
bottle it's like the bottle's normal
size right
Harris is
the good thing is I broke the water
bottle this week so I have to get a new
one but until now until then I'm giant
how do you get a water but what do you
Google on Amazon massive [ __ ] water
bottle yes no I went to Costco and found
it uh we're almost science to walk a
bottle of Costco
because you're obviously a very tiny
little one
is that why yeah
interview because like the doors you
can't get through the door
I saw the funniest Costco meme this week
it's like when you catch yourself buying
clothes at Costco that means you've
given up on yourself
I don't know what Costco is
it's this ginormous large big box store
uh that you have to be a member of it's
kind of like this
yeah yeah you're usually they're buying
books
Sam's Club almost if you know what that
is Walmart's fancy Walmart
no it's an American thing let's put it
on every building and charge you you
know Walmart or araster and then sold
our roster that's how I'm gonna warm up
and let's see when I was in America I
was in Walmart and we were trying to
find alcohol and we accidentally found
the gun aisle like wait what
Walmart's got anything and everything
that you need
um that was that was a very odd
experience I was like well we wanted a
bottle of whiskey what the hell
um two aisles over you can grab it yeah
we just we just walked a bit too far and
then then we had it because we'd already
we were already in a little bit we'd
already had a few we were only knowing
about what id we needed to buy a gun and
we're like you know can we just we've
got to drive and I said guys we've got a
passports man
we're in we're driving towards Vegas
a moment ago I'm pretty sure that's an
m16.
Jesus Christ is another 16. um it's 1916
though it was the British it was his
AR-15 AR-15 AR-10 yeah okay
we can actually buy an assault rifle fun
um but yeah
uh oh man America you guys have got it
it's [ __ ] crazy
we had we had a great time yeah yeah so
I do I do wonder what it's like there
for you guys Harris watching just to go
back to Stargate for one second
um I do honestly like for you to watch
this show because like saying I I watch
this showing for me though I'm watching
I'm really looking forward to watching
Atlantis again but I'm on I'm about
halfway through season five again but I
watched Stargate loads of times
um I watched sgdu recently just because
um I did a video saying SGS Target
Universe was boring and so anyway no it
isn't so I had to watch the series and
then by the end of it went yeah it is
boring
um
shut up it was
yeah
we'll stick with our sg1 shirts don't
worry
sorry stormy
or not not the best of the three you're
wrong mate you're just wrong
um it's
it is gritty and it is thin but it is
boring but it was getting better I will
say to you I wish it had got a third
season how many Sci-Fi series do we know
the first two seasons are not very good
um even sg1 the first season wasn't very
good
it feels okay star took the Next
Generation the first season was except
for a few little highlights was quite
bad you watch it back now it's like
Jesus is your [ __ ] happens if I make it
um the binars really annoyed me for some
reason I don't know why
yeah that whole series annoyed me so
they're watching it back now at the time
I loved it but watch it back now I'm
like this you I'm just waiting for
Geordie to get a random you know when
did he go from being a pilot to an
engineer how do you get that
qualification
um and then but as soon as he goes back
down to engineer and becomes the chief
in engineering completely randomly and
Tasha yard gets killed then the show
gets great but until then it's not very
good
except for conspiracy about the episode
in the first series is amazing
um
but uh but yeah but but lots of says so
I do wonder if it had got its SG would
have gotten better
um but I also think it was limited they
were really limited on what they were
actually able to do with it they painted
themselves into a corner with a whole
idea really
but um
but anyway I think it's just Super Hyper
specific on on if the show's gonna do
well those first few seasons I think a
lot of its budget Bob just commented the
expanse had a great first couple Seasons
those are probably the best seasons it
has I would actually argue the best
season of the expanses the first season
oh yeah it feels great that's the end of
that season it's just like what the hell
I I was almost disappointed with the
second season so I was just like this is
so much different what's going on and
then I'm realizing oh it's different for
a reason and I'm like okay I'm I'm with
this but um the first season was oh it
was just amazing it was Game of Thrones
for sci-fi yeah that's how I thought of
it and it also I don't know how y'all
feel about season five and six but
those were by far my least favorites
comparatively to Game of Thrones for
season seven and eight were by far my
least favorites there I feel like it
just kind of trailed off also I was
really mad they killed off Alex but
yeah
as well but um they were very much
trying to do something with expensive
women so that if they don't get to make
the rest
um
sort of thing so
but I keep going here we're gonna we're
gonna get more expanse so let's see what
happens fingers crossed keep hearing it
the most recent room I'm hearing though
is what I was told recently was
um
Amazon have got a year to take up the
option for another series and if they
don't
uh HBO Max one or Warner Brothers want
it do they have any money left I mean
you know
oh
the Warner Brothers aren't in financial
trouble no Amazon Amazon no I've got to
have no money left I mean you know after
the lavish spending on power of the rigs
which
is now a Nielsen rating uh leader
ironically and uh
I'm really struggling to find the
criticisms of it valid that anybody ever
[ __ ] had on the show it is just
top-notch y rings of power the last
episode is great yeah it suddenly dawned
on me though why it's so expensive
because that is it's it's not quite
but it's nearly very very nearly movie
quality yeah throughout and movies
nowadays cost two three hundred million
dollars to produce for two hours yeah so
all of a sudden if you think about
you're going to try to produce a TV show
that's 50 hours
and near Cinema quality which isn't some
people have been really moaning about
the some of the effects and I'm like
yeah okay some of the effects are a
little bit dodgy but let's remember this
is still a TV show compared to
everything else on the TV it's amazing
right what it's not it doesn't quite
compare to some aspects of you know the
it's what we're seeing at the cinemas
now
um some of the effects are a little
dodgy
um but I'm like 50 hours of near Cinema
quality and it's going at a pace now
we're seeing battles and things
[ __ ] expensive
that's ex I wasn't a fan of I I was a
fan of about half of episode six I
really didn't like the battle all as
much as I thought I would I didn't like
uh I didn't like the word story from
Mountain Doom I did and I didn't at the
same time
I I don't it just felt cheesy it didn't
feel earned and that
I don't know there was a lot of setup
but it didn't feel like any of the setup
Was Heard uh the other thing I thought I
didn't like about the volcano bit was
I'm not doing bit was I I'm there
looking at thinking that's not enough
War
[Music]
I think a lot of the things were
practical for me in that was just
could we have a little more it felt like
the numenoreans were arriving on land at
the same time and of course yeah they
were probably a day earlier but I would
have liked that to have been shown
because it feels like okay land we've
got a day ride all right we're there in
an hour and then they're fighting again
and then within the fighting I really
liked all of air and deer stuff I think
they they really are making him like the
legalist of the show in a lot of ways
and they're but not as perfect as I like
he gets his ass handed to him a few
times I do like I think it's like the
legless but Legolas never got a hand on
him he was never dirty this character is
a bit is a bit more sort of gritty and
you know not not as perfect having Orcs
bleed on you has that effect oh that was
horrible oh my God it was just like
coming and squirting out of his eye and
in this box
there's people that have those I they
hate eye violence and that was uh one of
those episodes that's perfect for it I
gotta I I'm an eye person I don't like
eye things I remember my mom's worse so
I got a speck of something in my eye
once and it went under the see-through
film
um so I had to have it syringed off my
eyeball
so a doctor had to stand over me and
just like with this with a syringe and I
was about 10 maybe so I was freaking out
the doctor said I sure probably
shouldn't have gone out drinking last
night or something along those lines and
my mom just literally looked at me went
you'll be fine won't you I'm [ __ ] off
I just have to have this thing syringed
off my eye and then like I wear an eye
patch for a couple of days and that was
all fine like but I was just like
oh mommy
did they have your eye Like A Clockwork
Orange open kind of deal just did yeah
they just held it open but um but now
I've got it
I've got the worst eye story if you want
to hear it why not okay so screw sci-fi
stuff Let's Talk About Eyes for a bit I
I was deep in the woods deep in the wood
far away from my car
hiking by myself that was mistake number
one
and I pushed this branch
out of my way this little Branch from a
sapling out of my way it flipped over my
hand and went right in my eye
and I couldn't see anything my eyes were
watering and hurt like hell and it took
like 20 30 minutes for me to just wash
whatever it was
I made it to a stream so just wash them
and it still hurt like hell and I
managed somehow to get back to my car at
the trailhead
yeah so I drove you know I was just
exhausted drove to the
to the local town and went to this real
little restaurant little out of the way
Family Restaurant
and they hand me the menu I opened it up
and it was blank
um and I thought they must be pranking
they said ma'am the the menus blank can
you bring me he says no it's it's it's
no there's words on it and then it hit
me oh [ __ ] so then I just took one hand
over the the uh put over the good eye it
was just blank did the opposite
oh I can see everything back when I knew
I'd really screwed up so I ate my on my
shrimp and then I went to the emergency
room
Hoots Memorial was the name of the
hospital that should have been my first
clue
um there was a the in the emergency
it's a [ __ ] hoot so anyway I went in
there and the only person on duty in the
emergency room was a resident
from local med school and he says well
you know that I don't see anything with
this big bright scope let me go get the
fluorescent dye we'll and so he's got
this bottle of fluorescent diet to try
to see if he can see anything in my eye
so he turns the bottle up
above my eye and the cap fell off no yes
into my damn eye and then what's the
first thing out of his mouth oh I can
see it now
yes is this [ __ ] poisonous that was like
that bit in a ring of power that stuff
would pour in your mouth
and so I had sliced my cornea almost all
the way or yeah all the way down to the
pupil and I still whenever I get my eyes
checked and so oh did you know you have
a scar across yes I did and so yes the
vision in this eye is really kind of
trotty because it's got that scar still
across the cornea it's not as good as
your story but I have got another eye
story oh I want to hear it yeah sure
complete coward
um I was just I don't know what it was
but I suddenly realized I couldn't see
very well out of this eye and I was like
something's not right like it was like I
had tunnel vision or something and I
remember
um my my wife at the time instead of
coming that says when can you see my
finger and I was just like
now and she's like oh okay someone's
gone wrong so I was just like oh Jesus
so I was virtually blind in this eye and
and nothing had happened so I went to
the doctors and they were saying well it
must be you must have detached the
retina and I was like I've sneezed or
something it's attached to retina ah
crap that that can't be good so I went
to the hospital and they did they put
that stuff in my eye that made me look
like a racoon
like that
um but she said I have to check the
pressure on the eyeball to make sure
it's not like am thing so it's this
machine and you have to put your chin on
it like that cool thing and then and it
it does of air
um but then this this little machine
comes up and it literally just touches
your eye and it takes a pressure thing
so I was just like okay you must stay
still and I'm like yep no problem I
might no yes
I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay this time
this time this time no
19 times oh my God to get the the
reading that she she wanted
[Music]
I hadn't done anything to my retina my
eyes are absolutely fine what I've done
was somehow I'd pulled a muscle here
sort of thing so this muscle it's sort
of like bangs and all it was literally
do is pulling my eye it was actually
pulling the eyeball ever so slightly so
you know obviously you've got your where
the the iris and then you've got the the
back of the eyeball and it it had pulled
my eye so the light basically wasn't
hitting the the and next day I could
feel it I could feel like it was like a
string across my face but I could feel
it the next day and I was like you know
doing that sort of thing and that's all
I've done I thought my eye was falling
after I had to go through that Bloody
machine and I look like a raccoon for
two days because my irises weren't like
that all because a muscle had pulled in
my eyeball I'm [ __ ] petrified yeah
why do you just freaking amazing though
that that's that's a thing you know it's
like it wasn't blinded me completely
blind in one eye
on the show and I'm perfectly fine with
that and after hearing those two stories
I got I got some some who has you know
I've got a full story it's one of the
days that you got to look forward
very interested in your back passage
when you turn 40. and they want to check
regularly
I'm just gonna I'll tell you this I'll
tell you this I'm not telling you the
whole story because it goes on for ages
but I'll tell you this this little bit I
had a doctor I had it I was I was really
unwell and I had this same thing and the
doctor wanted to check it wasn't my
um my colon so it says right we're just
gonna we're just gonna check so he you
know you'd bend over breathe deeply and
I was like oh yeah
um and then you know post things out and
I'm like okay and then he literally sent
me there and went right I'm not a
specialist so I'm gonna send you off I'm
gonna refer you to the things I'm like
so I'm sat there I'm not I'm not sat
there I'm like hovering over the chair
because what he's just done
if you didn't know what you were
checking for
why did you do it
not especially I'll just give it a go
you prick
give it a whirl so many that's what that
would be the equivalent to me at work
somebody gone tell me no problem mate
bend over I'll just check for you oh you
know what I don't actually know what I'm
checking for so don't do it so anyway
that story went on a little while and
it's a great way to end the video but
the first thing I did was I looked at
his hands as soon as he told me what he
was going to do and he was this big fat
fingered [ __ ] and I was like oh this
is gonna hurt so much and it did it was
horrible but yeah as soon as you turned
40 Harris
that's what you get to look forward to
you lucky lucky bunny
uh but there yeah
yeah well as a man
when you get a certain age
what kills you will almost certainly be
up your backside so it's worth
worth checking
all your heart obviously or your heart
one of the two one of the two so Champs
sure thank you so on that note on that
lovely note
um Bob's yesterday I'm just a janitor oh
I'll give it a look I'll give it a try
I'll give it a love too I'm hoping he
was a doctor yeah doctor in his name
maybe his name was just doctor but um
yeah he was going around like Doctor
Strange it was just a fake name
I remember about a year later I walked
in with flu or something and it was the
same doctor and I just don't know
not again yeah not again you hurt me
hurt me anyway so thank you guys so much
for another brilliant Jeff I think we've
sorted Stargate series four right
remember we were talking about Stargate
ages ago remember that yeah
it's wherever I go uh but thank you so
much chaps um hopefully again like I say
we will see you next week for more
hijinks and silliness
yeah I'll tell you my nipple story next
time
yeah that's brilliant
um story I just picked a body part on my
head I don't know why
next week
body parts and we'll have a
uh
stories about them probably we'll talk
about our x-rays in mucus yeah I'll tell
you about I I genuinely broke my
tailbone and didn't know for like 10
years
so I'll tell you that story
that's kind of intriguing I'll tell you
in a minute but did somebody have really
fat fingers or
foreign
yes that's exactly how it happened it
brings a whole new turn and did you have
to tip afterwards I'm just confused all
I'm saying is don't go to Amsterdam
they're mental
that is not true it's a joke that's not
what happens
guys say bye
may your tailbones be fortunate this
week
guys have a lovely week
Americans we'll see you next week don't
hike alone never that's best see you
later
[Music]